[Music]
in patients first news mm-hmm oh wait
I'm a patient right you're a patient and
I'm waiting patients somebody teach me
patience please submitted by you guys
get me through my tough times Oh that'll
be $100 surgeon gets injected with
painkillers for his own ruptured
appendix while he continues to perform
nine surgeries oh [ __ ] that sounds safe
that's not the boss this is India China
China Russia okay where is a shortage of
certain really if they're wise are such
a shortage of surgeons where you can't
just go home bring another one into
finish the operation because apparently
the night before that Hospital had a
power outage so they were back along the
sides on Saturdays dead
oh I see yeah and this takes place in
China oh how do we know well we kind of
guessed all of them yeah yeah what you
got it though yeah and so um apparently
he started that's dope he puts others
before him yeah you did
a surgery that day and he just had to
keep getting injected with pain fired
that's not trying to like behavior well
what if it was like I need that money
yeah I'm dying we're going to triple
your pay guess I'm not dying anymore
that's amazing though all jokes aside
that's [ __ ] me yeah that's really
honorable cuz if I was in pain I mean if
I have diarrhea I'm like hold up no
surgery I've gotta go take a [ __ ] that's
crazy
are you just doing this all the time oh
yeah I'm a damsel in distress well there
was a power outage in our department so
there was a lot of surgeries lined up
yesterday we doctors can't afford to get
thick if we get sick then the patients
have to wait I often worry about the
patients I just wanted to come to
complete their surgeries and help them
recover soon oh my god that's nice
Bravo dr. Liang so here he's performing
surgery this is him he's performing
surgery and he got hooked up to an IV
actually no sorry Q this is the
patient's IV he was getting injected
with painkillers right here by this
doctor here yeah
look dude that's funny what if the
doctor was giving surgery on him while
he's giving Sir John another like yeah
that's very green it's usually like
Ninja Turtles working on somebody that's
so cool yeah dude yeah these things are
really like the only specialists like
only Dr Lin can do it dr. Liang we need
your help
oh but my rapture rapture but my rat sir
I'm a rapture take me here you can see
him up against the wall in pain like
he's even it's he crouching down yeah oh
my god did he just finish a surgery and
go holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I think here he is
recovering he's pale as [ __ ] damn why
does he why does he look so young that's
he was honest look like Kim Jong Un's
little brother he was on his third
surgery when he started feeling like
this really sharp pain and and then
that's when he asked his supervisor to
be there with him
while he's doing all these these
surgeries pull my hand
[Laughter]
we did dump those guys a hero yeah I
know dude what if the whole country of
China has been watching our videos and
they're really really sad of the bad
marketing and PR that's been going on is
there fall [ __ ] they gave him
appendicitis so what no I mean he could
be an actor and all of this was staged
and China's like yo we got it we got to
change our marketing our branding right
now we're another sitting ban the scream
[ __ ] geo she's too smart a Mexican girl
is a genius you cannot pass a fast one
AHA well if you [ __ ] up every surgery
they have complications honorable how
are my patients
all dead okay but I'd take it away cuz I
can't remember over foot nobody asked so
anyway the surgeon who ended up
performing the surgery on him because he
had appendicitis Wow
he they said that his when they opened
him up that there was already pus oozing
out and that his appendix was about 10
centimeters long almost as thick as her
thumb and how long is it supposed to be
I don't know I think it supposed to be
like super small - eh what the [ __ ] did
he eat homie it's not what you eat cuz I
got my appendix taken out to hurt so
much it's one of those things where
people thought you didn't probably need
it for anything because they didn't know
what the function of it was right
where's your appendix located on my
lower left right
what is this right where your lighter
back here in a day we probably used it
for something I have a scar right here
right here and right here
callate they went in laparoscopically
okay did it get infected where does it
hurt though let me see cuz I might have
a similar paper Oh on my right side
like they couldn't determine it was
crazy if they had to open me up first to
find out what was wrong with me because
since I'm a woman I have a lot of [ __ ]
down there they're like it could be
something else I was like I'm gonna hurt
you
that is pretty crazy they're like first
we have to open to even see ya then they
go appendicitis
that's literally what she just FETs it I
wanted to act it out gio okay we're
gonna act out the [ __ ] parts let me
do my [ __ ] I'm an artist go act it out
already Dini
oh you missed out on the big performance
it was it was great what was it it was
great it was great it was great great
will the pain like oh it was really
sharp pains uh so for me it was nine
months after I gave birth so I thought
it was something to do with that because
I had a c-section yeah and so I thought
maybe there's a complication or
something I don't I remember waking up
one morning and just having it's they
actually the pain actually started on my
left side oh wow yeah it was weird
so it started on my left side and they
would like come in it was like waves but
by the time I hit the peak of Sharpe
does it feel like on her left side like
that like everyone's all like was it a
sharp pain it was no it was like it
would like be gradual and then it hit me
like sharp and then goes back down but
then I ended up moving I remember
calling the nurse hotly yeah cuz I don't
want to go there's a nurse hotline they
talk dirty a [ __ ] with nurse are you
sick tell me yeah the Kaiser the Kaiser
no where does it hurt bad girl sexy hot
nurses all help me nurse allergic to any
medication I know yeah anyway Casilla
yeah and then by the time I was on the
phone with her the pain moved to the
right side and then she was like you
need to go to the ER there are action
this is a hospital what does I know it's
not [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you just
call oh my god
remember I had a pain right here from
the side so I had a random pain I think
maybe like a month or two ago I was
showering at the JK office and all sides
collapse on the floor it was like a
really sharp pain I'm just like sitting
in the water and I was just like trying
to do it long breaths
and I don't know what it was and then
slowly I got up and I don't know if it
was like a internal cramp or like I
thought it was maybe all the artificial
sweeteners I've been eating from like
the pre-workout so I cut pre-workout I
didn't know what it was but I didn't
come back but oh that's good I was
trying to wait it out throughout the day
yeah now Mike is it is he gonna move to
this side has it happened before
I mean or since then a little slight
pain but it blows away how come you
don't ever go to Oh Oh check it out he
does it it went away that doesn't mean
that it came back but it wayno not as
much to where I'm gonna be upon the
floor and it went away it is I'll be
going to the hospital all the time do
these know me now at this point because
you need to go they have in the VIP car
you've caught dude they just call me
what exploded dude my name over there
yeah I used to like did not going to the
hospital but then every time I went
something seriously went wrong so I was
like maybe I should go see you learn
your lesson yeah so like a lot of the
stuff that I ignored could have been
prevented if I would have just dealt
with it when it happened so it would
just like be prolonged as [ __ ] like that
so I got a question about this guy go
the surgeon who prefer performed his
surgery he worked at the same hospital
then what the [ __ ] was he doing on a
Secretary's board there was another
surgeon man he's a dick it's just one of
the all the garage I'll say is it
specialist link like he didn't mention
that if he's like you'd be the
supervisor education oh yeah like if
one's a lung guy and younger guys like
appendix Connie all nine of the
surgeries was the same [ __ ] maybe that's
not some dick I don't know how the
hospital works they're nice to work with
that doctor Miami they do
bbl and tummy tuck in the same
brazilian butt-lift plastic surgeon
their good friend oh they do all kinds
of stuff yeah this one's a boob one this
one's about one yeah but like a heart
surgeon is only gonna work on the heart
that I can't look at open human bodies
man that [ __ ] is so disgusting
I followed this medical school IG and
it's them crate like you see bones
fingers cry do you follow medical school
IG I'm just so interested like they tell
you like what happened like how how this
person has like his hand opened up and
then they they show you after of what
they did to sew it up and how it fits in
it's amazing no it's weird I can't see
it in a video but I was perfectly fine
in person saying like a freaking open
heart chest like right there no no what
that mean you're a serial killer did no
I don't know it was just so interesting
to me and then my god oh no it's not
interesting I saw a video of like it was
I can't see it in video cuz then I get
gross out doing Netflix there's this
thing where they just open up like
extremely like morbidly obese people and
they just show you like what's inside
them and they just do it like it's
nothing they're like well this right
here is a oversized kidney and I'm just
looks wrong and they're cutting the body
open and then you just see and it looks
like that in Star Wars where they cut
open that Camel all that fat came out
yeah that's what it looks like oh I
can't even that it's gross
yeah I wonder if I could handle it now
since it's been so many years away from
all that [ __ ] cuz I said sterilize the
surgical instrument so like sometimes
they'll come in and they'll be like a
bone meat chunks which should not be in
my department they should not have any
bio stuff there oh yeah one time I saw a
[ __ ] hemorrhoid still on the clamp
and I'm like what the [ __ ] you guys have
to throw this [ __ ] away to me
hammer it on the clap that's like booty
juice all up in that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]